[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission on va
parler de commerce et de commerciaux
avec Pierre-olivier Gifa bonjour bonjour
Patrice vous êtes vous êtes enseignants
à l'ESCE
International Business School et vous
enseignez
le marketing notamment voilà c'est ça et
puis tout ce qu'il avait tourné autour
de autour de la vente absolument et
alors on va découvrir avec vous le
dernier livre que vous avez écrit qui
s'appelle commerciaux assuré de vos
premières ventes chez ma édition est
allé très sympathique parce que
évidemment il s'adresse aux gens qui
veulent faire une carrière de vendeur
mais on découvre même si on n'est pas
beaucoup de choses parce que c'est un
livre très pédagogique au fond cette
jeune fille qui s'appelle Camille je
crois
qui voilà qui veut devenir vendeuse et
qui pose qui posent des questions à
quelqu'un qui
qui la conduit dans cette dans cette
voie là et et donc c'est très didactique
c'est très c'est très joyeux même c'est
très simple de
d'abord aimer on en prend beaucoup de
choses d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est les commerciaux
parce qu'on dit les commerciaux mais il
y a 10 métiers ou 15 métiers différents
non exactement il y a des dizaines de
différents types de métiers autour de la
fonction commerciale on va dire que la
priorité du commercial c'est de vendre
c'est de développer le chiffre
d'affaires la rentabilité de son
entreprise c'est ce qu'on appelle un
petit peu la vitrine de l'entreprise
face aux prospects face aux clients et
ce livre je l'ai conçu justement pour
une particularité de commerciaux ce
qu'on appelle les ingénieurs d'affaires
les ingénieurs d'affaires c'est ceux qui
vont être amenés à travailler sur des
ventes complexes au niveau de tout ce
qui va être la prospection évidemment la
négociation et la fidélisation derrière
de leur de leur compte alors justement
pour commencer un mot sur lequel vous
incitez un peu dans le livre c'est celui
de vente complexe alors il y a la vente
simple alors avant de simple je sais pas
je vais acheter votre livre voilà ça
c'est une vente simple
je donne un peu d'argent c'est qu'on
vient d'ailleurs tiens le prix non vous
savez combien ils ont il était à 24 € 90
€ 90 et pour 24 heures 90 j'ai
commerciaux assuré dès vos premières
ventes donc ça c'est simple ça c'est
simple c'est vous c'est moi voilà c'est
alors complexe alors complexe déjà
potentiellement on va être plusieurs
imaginons que vous soyez le représentant
d'une compagnie aérienne et que vous
soyez intéressé par acheter de nouveaux
avions pour votre flotte d'accord donc
vous voyez le produit c'est l'avion
d'accord mais derrière le produit il va
y avoir un certain nombre de
caractéristiques un certain nombre
finalement de critères sur lequel vous
allez faire votre choix imaginons
l'aménagement de la cabine donc là il va
falloir quelque part parler architecture
architecture d'intérieur pour configurer
la cabine on va également parler mot
donc là il va falloir avoir une
composante motoriste que vous n'avez pas
que je n'ai pas donc on va se faire
accompagner chacun de nos experts donc
il y a une multiplication d'intervenants
exactement donc c'est un petit peu cette
notion vendre complexe veut dire multi
interlocuteurs et un coordinateur ce
coordinateur qui va être l'ingénieur
d'affaires donc le commercial dans ce
cadre-là d'accord et c'est évidemment
sur ces bons complexes que vous
que vous fassiez votre complexe c'est la
manière de les faire que vous expliquer
vous dites aussi
au début dans l'introduction que le
métier de vendeur de commercial
a énormément changé énormément évolué
absolument il a plus évolué en disant
que les centres précédentes années en
fait nos sociétés exactement c'est à
dire que la banque
il y a internet il y a les réseaux
sociaux donc aujourd'hui par exemple
faire de la prospection quand on est
quand on est commercial c'est utiliser
les réseaux sociaux utiliser ce qu'on
appelle le social selling donc ça ce
sont des techniques de prospection sur
lequel il est intéressant d'avoir des
connaissances d'avoir des techniques à
maîtriser sachant que le premier outil
de prospection reste encore Patrice le
téléphone le téléphone et ça reste quand
même c'est encore le premier routier
avoir quelqu'un à qui on parle ça attire
plus que recevoir un mail ou alors
ça va dépendre
on voit comme vous le disiez la société
évolue le téléphone est encore le
premier outil de prospection mais si on
se revoit dans trois ans ce serait
peut-être plus ça sera plus simple donc
la digitalisation en fait va nous amener
à revoir un certain nombre d'outils de
prospection de fidélisation et c'est
aussi ce qui fait l'intérêt de ce métier
c'est que on évolue en fonction des
outils le premier outil que vous allez
utiliser en entreprise quand vous êtes
commercial ça va être ce qu'on appelle
le CRM customer relationship management
c'est la base de données où vous avez
l'ensemble des interactions avec vos
contacts exactement
la visio ça on s'en sert alors la vision
s'en sert on s'en est servi un peu à
l'insulte plein gré les dernières années
évidemment mais ce que l'on voit c'est
c’était extrêmement pratique c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir sur
votre complexe exactement quelqu’un aux
États-Unis quelqu'un en Australie
deux autres en France etc tout à fait
mais il faut en gagner un temps fou
quand même en gagnant un temps fou mais
avec un niveau de préparation qui est
également important parce qu'il faut
faire en sorte que ces réunions c'est
téléconférence soit efficace donc le
commercial va être le coordinateur de
ces réunions et il va falloir derrière
qu'il soit aussi persuasif dans son
animation dans sa dans sa vente donc
c'est une très belle opportunité
technologique mais ça demande
l'acquisition également de compétences
pour sa mise en oeuvre mais est-ce que
vous verrez que rien ne remplace la
rencontre physique si je peux dire
présentiel comme on dit ça c'est l'idéal
c'est à dire la possibilité de se
rencontrer la possibilité d'échanger la
possibilité d'aller vraiment dans le
maximum d'interactions avec son
interlocuteur sauf que il faut aussi
pouvoir évoluer il faut pouvoir
s'adapter et puis il faut aussi
bénéficier de ces atouts et quand vous
parliez de téléconférence c'est quand
même un plus de se dire on va pas
attendre trois mois pour se voir
voyager dans trois pays différents
c'est difficile pour commercial
justement d'avoir ce contact d'avoir
d'obtenir ce rendez-vous le premier
rendez-vous le premier rendez-vous ce
qu'on appelle
c'est la prospection il faut derrière
que je vous intéresse que je réponde
surtout à un besoin si je viens vous
voir en vous parlant de piscine et que
vous êtes en appartement on oublie donc
ça veut dire que de ma part en tant que
commercial je dois bien qualifier que
vous avez un intérêt sur le produit le
service que je vais commercialiser et
puis ensuite il faut que j'arrive à vous
contacter donc par exemple je vais vous
contacter en regardant sur les réseaux
sociaux je vais vous contacter en
essayant d'obtenir votre numéro de
téléphone votre adresse etc donc ça
c'est un travail de préparation qui est
extrêmement important
dans ce livre sur l'importance de la de
la préparation la préparation ça va être
plus de 50% du succès d'une affaire
c'est comme c'est comme le sport si vous
êtes le meilleur footballeur du monde
c'est que vous ne vous entraînez pas
voilà donc là pareil le commercial doit
se préparer et ça consiste en quoi la
préparation justement alors la
préparation ça va consister en déjà une
phase d'information qui est la personne
notamment quand je suis dans les
rendez-vous professionnels avec des
représentants
qui êtes-vous quelles sont vos centres
d'intérêts quelles informations ai-je
sur votre entreprise et sur vous
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on a déjà
précédemment été amené à avoir des
relations commerciales ce qui est pas ce
qui est un cas
je vais également regarder avec qui vous
travaillez potentiellement vous avez des
contacts avec des concurrents de ma
société donc je vais me renseigner je
vais regarder leur site je vais
également regarder votre actualité pour
voir quelles sont les éléments sur
lequel vous seriez plus sensible que
d'autres donc tout ce travail c'est
vraiment être capable de préparer son
dossier et quand on va être amené à se
rencontrer à ce moment-là je vais pas
vous poser des questions trop basiques
je vais en revanche valider les éléments
que j'ai pu collecter d'accord donc ça
c'est ça c'est fondamental qu'on
n'arrive pas à les mains dans les poches
on peut des artistes mais ça marche
généralement pas ça marche pas
des processeurs à respecter bien un mot
parce que peut-être que tout le monde
sait ce que c'est mais pas forcément
vous dites qu'il y a deux grandes sortes
de relations le B2B aussi
je dirais même si on a trois si on
complexifier en frais du site aussi et
du site aussi alors
si c'est relation avec le client c'est
ça exactement c'est l'entreprise en
relation avec le client quand vous allez
dans un magasin acheter des chaussures
ben vous êtes en face d'une entreprise
et vous êtes le particulier d'accord
donc ça c'est vraiment le mode classique
qu'on a l'habitude de vivre en tant que
consommateur ensuite vous avez le B2B le
B2B ça va être un commercial en face de
l'acheteur d'une entreprise donc vous
allez non plus vous intéresser aux
besoins de la personne mais au besoin de
l'entreprise qui est en face de vous
tout à l'heure je parlais d'exemple des
avions un constructeur avec derrière une
compagnie aérienne d'accord un acheteur
un vendeur et le site aussi le site
aussi c'est quand on va faire un
vide-grenier dans notre dans notre ville
et à ce moment-là on est de
consommateurs à consommateur un décor de
consommateur
et donc là vous vous adressez quand même
plutôt professionnel enfin aux gens qui
qui font du commerce en prof veulent
faire du commerce dans les entreprises
c'est un secteur en expansion qui
recrute beaucoup je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs j'en suis convaincu c'est
certainement l'un des secteurs qui
recrute le plus aujourd'hui en France
parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir cette
dynamique de développement avec
l'internationalisation avec les réseaux
sociaux vous vous devez d'avoir les bons
profils pour développer votre votre
entreprise votre chiffre d'affaires et
c'est une très belle opportunité pour
les jeunes d'évoluer dans ce genre de
métier donc il y a des emplois
absolument emploi généralement comme ça
quand on est vendeur on a un peu les
images c'est pas du bonimenteur ou des
types qui a du bagou de la femme qui a
du wagon
est-ce que ça suffit ça non c'est ça a
changé là aussi le but du jeu quand on
parle de négociation dans l'esprit alors
je le vois avec les avec les jeunes ils
imaginent que c'est je vends à tout prix
vendre c'est une chose moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas de vous vendre une
voiture si je suis
commercial dans l'automobile c'est
évidemment vous vendre une voiture mais
que dans trois ans quand vous allez
vouloir renouveler votre véhicule vous
veniez me voir donc ceci donc c'est
établir une relation on parle vraiment
de win-win il faut que ce soit
gagnant-gagnant que quand vous achetiez
la voiture vous ayez vraiment la
conviction que vous avez acheté la
voiture qui vous correspond et que moi
en tant que vendeur j'ai la conviction
d'avoir vendu le modèle qui vous
correspond donc on est sur du
gagnant-gagnant et on entame une
relation et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que cette relation
professionnelle elle va nous permettre
de gagner du temps la prochaine fois
qu'on se ramené à se voir on est plus
dans alors que fait fou qui êtes-vous
etc
exactement c'est vraiment le point qui
est important pas une vente mais la
construction d'une d'une relation entre
entre deux personnes ou entre deux
entreprises je disais sympathique pour
terminer il y a un quiz à la fin qui
résume qui résume piégé non pas
forcément non bah non vous devez écrire
non mais par exemple laquelle de ces
trois phrases pensez-vous être la plus
appropriée durant les 20 premières
secondes de votre première rencontre je
vous remercie de me recevoir c'est la
photo de votre famille là derrière vous
ou tenez voici ma carte de visite allez
20 premières secondes c'est la première
impression qu'on va laisser donc il faut
pas qu'on se trompe donc j'aurais
tendance à dire si je veux caricaturer
je vais parler de votre famille mais on
se connaît pas
si je vous dis je vous donne ma carte de
visite ça fait un peu voilà qui je suis
tout de suite ça peut créer on va dire
une barrière c'est parce que je veux en
revanche vous voyez tout à l'heure quand
on s'est rencontré je vous remercie je
suis ravi d'être là et que vous
m'accorder du temps donc on va être
vraiment sur cette phrase là
expliquez un mot dans la méthode son
cases quelle motivation correspond au
suicide garantie et de service
après-vente petit alconfort petit Bella
sécurité petit c'est l'orgueil alors il
faut peut-être dire un mot de ce qu'est
la méthode 115 alors la méthode sont
caisses en fait quand on achète un
produit un service on a plusieurs
motivations d'achat mais on en a
généralement une qui est principale et
cette motivation elle va se décliner en
fonction de la sécurité l'orgueil elle
peut être également autour de la
nouveauté pour le dernier produit ça
peut être également le confort je veux
quelque chose qui soit pratique simple à
utiliser l'argent ma principale
motivation c'est le meilleur qualité
rapport qualité prix ou alors la
sympathie le commercial est quelqu'un
d'agréable et je suis content de passer
un moment ou alors le dernier puisqu'on
parle de son casque qui est féminin
c'est l'environnement je veux faire
aussi un achat qui est en fonction de la
protection de la de la planète et de mon
engagement sociétal donc chaque achat
chaque produit que l'on sur lequel on
est amené à se positionner on va voir
cette motivation si j'achète une voiture
je vais privilégier par exemple la
sécurité parce que c'est important pour
moi de protéger ma famille quand je veux
acheter un smartphone j'aime bien la
nouveauté le dernier produit
de se souvenir et donc dans le cas que
vous avez cité la motivation est autour
de la de la sécurité exactement
Pierre-Olivier Giffard commerciaux
assuré dès vos premières ventes oui
parce qu'il faut donner que vous dites
la bonne impression dès le début c'est
chez Emma édition et puis et puis voilà
vous pouvez suivre vos cours si on
rentre à l'ESC avec un grand plaisir
d'ailleurs c'est grâce à mes étudiants
que j'étais amené à écrire ce livre
puisque finalement plutôt que de faire
de questions réponses j'ai créé ce
dialogue avec avec Camille et je l'ai
partagé avec avec mes étudiants c'est
pas pour autant qu'il faut pas venir
beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Patrice
[Musique]